you
let's try one of these I'm the first one
to enter three-minute tournament and
these are the players who are now
jumping in I was the first to enter and
we have we have all games rolling here
five games six players here we go
all right hmm okay I want to help my
queen out and this pawn is unprotected I
don't see it as accessible I want to get
this bishop working that I might want to
do that with b4 no I'm gonna I'm gonna
be more confident I definitely want to
do that would be for now never mind
let's just go b3 I I don't want to have
to worry about a couple captures on that
square in this pawn moving the bishop
hitting I gotta go faster this is not so
long off from being a very a very what a
very a very what am I trying to say it's
not so easy to focus on accommodating
while you're playing this could turn out
to be very natural-looking position from
regular chess so my knight is hit I got
to watch out for Forks a little bit it
can mess up my pawn structure and then
this guy will become incredibly weak
without my e pawn around when my e pond
is converted to an F pawn my deep on
suffers if I can't get d4 in I'll
struggle so my king is going to knock
castle or maybe he well maybe you won't
I've got to decide he's gonna go here I
need to babysit this pawn not the
greatest thing to do and let me get my
knight here and follow through with what
I getting rid of this guy alright so
I've done just that I'm artificially
castled and my knight is ready to
rhumble here I get all my pieces working
let's take that guy is the queen gonna
take maybe I could play queen here oh my
winning material even night here that
looks pretty good actually let's do that
I was going to to be perfectly honest I
was going to play my I've rook to d1 but
oh this is netting the whole farm right
that's that's a fork and a half my queen
is gone I was hitting the rook and the
bishop the King does have to throw
himself in the corner right yeah that's
GG putting this gun that queen is gone
alright let's keep things really simple
here mate threat on g7 I'm hitting here
everything is said I'm just up a full
Queen right now those tricky Knights man
those tricky Knights get the best of
everybody everybody to make sure he
doesn't get me back in any way here
alright I am content with just trading I
did consider for a quick second of just
taking that night
all right the down the down the typical
domino effect down one piece the others
fall all righty
that was round one let's see what's
going on elsewhere right here Dill's
gambit versus hi Jerry
all right my first thought is that h3 is
a scary pun this pond is super scary can
you imagine a queen on g2 just imagine a
queen on g2 and how dangerous she would
be Queen takes pawn is not available
rook F to e1 I know it is available ah
way to make me sound like a fool this
isn't this isn't available and then it's
played oh yeah it is
for a second I thought the rook was
unprotected Ani eight this Queen has
been converted into pac-man II for a for
maybe a bishop is in her future no no if
Queen takes Bishop Bishop takes here
black is now geared up on this dog and I
looking for me in some way on h1 h1 to
g2 stuff how do you break down this
knight he's a tough guy and soon this
dark square bishop is going to be
rumbling these bishops are kind of stuck
if you can't know if I'm a fan of that
oh that's an interesting recapture you
can't you take with the Queen there's
eventually some fork at the end of it
now now white is returning the favour'
putting pressure on this square now we
have check King here I don't like
throwing the King in the corner now
there's back rank issues or maybe if the
bishop is here then the king is stuck
for life in the corner that's never a
good thing you never remember you never
want to be stuck for life on the h1
square never Black is now eyeing up that
G 2 square we also have a significant
time edge
and pressure here big pressure looking
for a tricky maid again on g7 in black
is saying now I will just simplify 2.7
seconds as well not enough time
tricky checks bishops dead checks over
here time burners two seconds to 13
seconds less than a second tougher
stalemate there's no stalemates
game over Black ends up winning that one
on time and also position okay that is
it round one is over round two is
beginning alright this one comes to mind
anything unprotected
nothing's unprotected this comes to mind
Knight here's gonna be awkward but let
me do this first or maybe this now let's
do this get my knight here these are
pretty natural moves and development
shouldn't be too bad I've seen it much
worse and now okay already I want to
focus on this square this d4 square is
weakened and I'm gonna try and make him
a bad piece let me let me let me get rid
of my darts for a bishop if my opponent
even allows me maybe Knight c3 oddly
played I would really welcome a dark
square Bishop exchange even at the cost
of some temple gaining moves such as f4
so oh I could even get my knight in here
let me do that okay things are already
working quite well with these two moves
d4 is weakened and I really want to
focus this I want to focus d4 has my
attention d4 has my attention there and
I need some breathing space for my
bishop so let's get b6 in I need to
castle I could castle but I'm not going
to right now
why not I'm not sure
maybe I don't want a castle maybe I
could go queenside maybe see this move
is gonna be played I think okay this is
I just I have to move Oh why'd I go with
that piece oh I wanna do that f4 can be
played now mostly can I claim a mouse
lip it's actually pretty rare - Mouse
lip with the night
it's those tricky puns or you know I do
you yeah did you really mean to do that
or this the Knights though he's tricky
but it's tough to Mouse lip with the
night that's a fun fact isn't it a fun
blitz fact anyhow f-4e five my opponent
could in some sense start to steamroll
me here am I gonna get steamrolled f4
I'm gonna drop all the way back here oh
you know why I did that move let's go
back home I think I go here he's dead
there goes my plan right there he was my
genius plan let's treat dark spirit
bishops let's go here for a second and
then get kicked away a couple moves
later
that was wonderful that was wonderful
right there how in the world am I gonna
get Castle let's do this stop this
Knight from doing anything fancy
I could still Castle queenside oh that's
a mate threat
hang on hang on we saw this in the last
game threatening on g7 was my opponent
watching that game instead of playing I
have some tricky stuff maybe lined up
he's a defender right now but he's a
he's also an attacker he's also gonna
beat half pressure on him Knight c2 and
then what do I have up my sleeve nothing
fun hang on this diagonal is open so
he's starting to smile a little bit more
he's definitely starting to smile a
little bit more isn't he okay if Queen
here I do this and then close to a queen
trade maybe
yeah she's got to get out of there she
has to go there she is going there
let's get my bishop back here that's
where he wanted to go that's where he
belongs get him there get in get in the
hole on e5 I just for a second there
thought about Adam Sandler happy gilmore
who knows that scene I brought that up a
while ago did that
okay take with the pun I want to keep
the night out I actually have a time
edge it's usually my opponent who was
flying okay I still have yet to declare
my uh my King's intentions do I even
know what his intentions are it just
feels right to have my LightSquared
Bishop doing something like that let's
play here and actually I'm gonna make
sure this bishop is not going to do
anything to harm me actually here comes
a deadly night no let's get rid of the
night this is a closed position I like
my night the night is more valuable than
he's still pinned I'm gonna take him
voluntarily though I'm gonna drop back
these guys are dead right the bishops
aren't really doing a whole lot now I
can't Castle queenside but maybe I don't
need to this Bishop is ready to rumble
let's do this though jump my knight in
here this is a nice nice support point
pressure on this square I casted
artificially he needs to do something
more that's good doubled up here more
pressure that was a mouse slip you see
what I was talking oh my LightScribe
better do something else
run trade let's train I get back here
take like that more trades oh that's a
free queen they were down on time though
right
very little time I'm usually the one
who's way behind on the clock versus a
GM all right oh this games done let's
see this one let's see this one all
right round two the round two game's
over
I should have looked at the standings
but I don't want to cut away just yet
less than two seconds never a good sign
never alright that game is over black
wins alright standings leaders leaders 2
2 1 1 0 0 alright ah what do we do here
we do this move so that there the Queen
doesn't have any bright ideas of
grabbing this pawn my bishop is helped
out let's get this pawn rolling you get
my knight here my Queen has some
breathing space could capture here and
double my pawns but that's a serious
concession giving up that dark square
bishop light square weaknesses as soon
as that move was played hmm let's get
him doing something I want to do this
get my darks our bishop ow I need him
working let's expand on the Queen side
this is very very English opening ish
English opening ish right bishop checks
okay this is going to be quite weakening
now for my opponent no castling their
King is vulnerable and without my dark
square Bishop around I don't know that
I've really expressed it in this way
before but without that one of your
bishops around the Queen will I've seen
in many cases like to be around on the
on the dark squares if you don't have a
dark square Bishop so it's Castle let's
get a for b5 stuff in and yeah I want to
go in this direction I want to increase
this bishops mobility more pressure on
c6 if this pawn moves then this is a
wonderful home my knight is getting
kicked around so let's run away Knight
here I have to have be concerned about
that the B file is likely to open if
it's going to be prevented that means I
get the d5 square and I could look to
maneuver my Knights about so that they
occupy that square I can also think
about d4 I can also think about just
capturing right now and opening up the
position Adam
where I have a lead in development and
even though I have this safer King
position trading Queens I think is still
quite alright because I certainly have a
very active rook and my opponent is
having to watch over this pawn with
pieces which is not a good sign and now
I could pin this Knight and I believe
win it
I think King here was needed yeah this
is this is just a pin in a win this
night is four moves away from getting to
this square I should say three moves
away from defending this Knight but I
could take him but I don't need to it's
not going anywhere let me address this
night trying to give me any issues he's
not going anywhere in fact maybe I'll go
here next oh why did I miss that move
okay well let me take the knight and go
in this direction that was silly well
he's still stuck there's pressure here
so now this hole is there I'm on the
bishop I'm on here just get my Knights
working let's get my rook active yeah
here seems good I'm taking the bishop
and then taking here that's a thought
get my other bishop on this Square my
knight somehow here 146 to about a
minute you can pick up that again the
two minor pieces rook takes Bishop rook
takes Knight Bishop to d5 rook here do I
have to be concerned about it rook
getting to that Square and now I could
take again this guy's pinned that turns
out to be a free rope less than 45
seconds all right resignation good game
let's close out of that that's round
three round three there's this game
going on there's still those two other
games and things are looking good for
Team white this is going to be a
difficult opponent definitely 25/16 soon
enough
and then yeah this is this is a unless
there's a custom Comcast gambit that
white experiences they are going to win
this game and they did black just
resigned
one more game going on this one right
here
Dill's gambit versus a GM chess so a
much more tightly contested game here
three four five six seven four material
is even the position can open up soon
but black has some pressure here this
seems natural this actually seems like a
really good home for the night oh that's
better
I was thinking this first but you know
what it permits I think it permits this
bishop pin of the night so that since
you're interesting this night cannot be
kicked from this square a six
eirick sunni h6 seems like a good useful
move or strengthening move defending the
night allowing him to move without the h
pawns capture 34 seconds to 27 seconds
this is going to be a tight one right
here can't capture there's this pin here
now one two three four pieces are
hitting this pawn this can now be
captured we could enter a rook and pawn
it or a King and pawn endgame and in
that king upon endgame who stands better
that's still a tough call because these
three pawns have a difficult time
actually breaking through against double
isolated pawns on the G file this King
has a really strong position this
Knights position is maintained this
Bishop is pinned and actually this pawn
push is not long ha from happening
that's prevented you can't do g6 without
dropping this ponceau 11 seconds each
Knight takes rook takes here black is
winning clearly upper rook time wise
however white is winning eight seconds
to six seconds avoid the rook exchange
oh don't go here oh you're gonna get
made it over here oh the rooks could
have played here and the black would
just need to do what while they were
throwing the time brainer point nine
point four point two two point two no
time black wins
good game alright Oh round four coming
up oh man this is the guy Dill's he was
just playing a game this is uh oh this
is gonna be regular chat soon
it's gonna be regular chess as soon as I
could get my queen out of the corner all
right let's get my bishop outside in my
pond chain I could castle without moving
I don't need to move my Queen to Castle
Knight f3 yeah this is gonna be regular
chess before you not o my bishop has a
ton of possibilities I could play here
force the rook to move and come back I'm
gonna actually do that okay this is
actually a useful move because it gets
in the way the rook and it removes
castling privilege so I can already now
anticipate the black King having it to
Castle queenside and he's not having a
fun day let's get my knight here or do I
want to play this I want to do this I
want to stop the knight from kicking my
bishop or capturing my bishop so let's
do this
I need to be cautious about black being
able to open up the position because
this is not a developing move it's
strictly preventive let's get my knight
working my queen should also do
something more I think my queen wants to
be placed on e to b4 i Castle otherwise
it's going to be much more difficult to
get my Queen working so the plan here
the the issue that I really want you to
solve is to get my queen on e 2 and only
then castle I won't have any issues on
the Queen side I better be able to know
how to get those pieces working that is
the original setup and that's on that
side of the board so Queen e to
reinforce my Center now this move is not
long off and it may be happening quite
soon this could actually turn out to be
problematic Knight a5 Bishop C to d5 I
can't do d3 to reinforce this pawn so
what does this mean it means I have to
give up my light square bishop because I
don't want my Center to crumble and if
this Bishop is taken now at least I get
play along the a file since we are
castle on opposite wings I need to be
concerned about
opening having my end of the board
opened up and I'd like to have this
position open up for for me here I want
the queenside to open up let's get my
knight working he's defended by my
knight and bishop if this capture does
occur and maybe now I actually do avoid
the bishop exchange so I could get these
temple gaining pawn advances in let's
let's do this so we're both going to be
running with our pawns who was going to
be the quicker side actually I'm gonna
do this I was gonna do this move first
but oh I was expecting night here Knight
b3 I think would have been a good reply
so do I keep going with my apon I think
I do I need to I need to open up the I
need to open up a file so this is
direction I'm going in my opponent is
also coming at me it's a big race who's
gonna get there first pawn push here
night here Knight g6 g5 I don't have
Knight h4 so and I don't want to make a
pawn move or maybe I do maybe I do after
all no that's so scary isn't it so scary
I am going to do what I'm gonna run over
here yeah and if pawn push I think I
don't know if I want to with my knight
here cuz I have to anticipate I hope
I've everything covered I have to
anticipate a knight playing to f4 and I
want my Bishop to be able to take them
so let's trade here pawn push I play
Knight here
it seems very active a minute thirty to
less than a minute Knight here he's I'm
taking him in a blink in a blink ok
these rooks are obstructed I think I
still keep marching here let me keep
marching these pawns are gonna push my
knight around soon oh ok he's gotta go I
cannot deal with that guy no way
actually maybe I could do this move you
gotta jump my knight in here I don't
want my knight to be kicked around I was
I'm really scared about this g5 move
let's do this let's do this I want to
get it my opponents King I'm thinking
too defensively you see what I was just
doing there shame on me for trying to
think too defensively and my pawn is
having none of it none of it I gotta
kill that piece he's just bad news
how're you slice it however you slice it
it's just bad news all right
actually take care I'm thinking about
just taking this bishop and I should yes
take my knight and then this Bishop is
going to be a really good defender in
fact I'm going to have a ton of pressure
on this pawn ton of pressure on this
pawn let me let me get these temple
gating moves in so I'm down material but
I certainly have opened up the black
King better than Who am I trying to say
let's let's capture with the pond and
keep my opponent in a pin Knight here is
the deadly threat and this this rook is
dead so I'm getting material back and
actually I'm up material now so the last
phase is to make sure okay they resign
would be to make sure I have a flight
square that was a really good battle
very very nice game all right so that
came over and there's 100 oh I wasn't
even able to look this is little is this
the last game okay I have to get on my
feet this is not the first time whoa
hang on their age 7 was hit now I'm
hitting h2 watch out for h2 what's this
Knight up to I could castle
I could definitely castle let's get my
Knights out
let's get those tricky nights out night
into this square I could do this I think
this is a better square let me get
castle watch out for the main threat on
g7 I'd scream I'd scream if I missed
that night here it could be an annoying
move maybe I should have considered that
more oh they're going in Reverse that's
always good to see I think I mean look
this is what I was trying to do in the
previous game let's see if I can make
that happen
he's gonna go here not gonna kick kick
I'm gonna eventually get kicked again
with that for no not in this game not in
this game I want to keep him around
because he wants to jump into this
ground let me go here voluntarily
because he's gonna be kicked anyhow
can I make sure this Bishop doesn't kill
me let's do this keep the knight out of
that square it also makes this move
available and this move is happening
isn't it
it certainly is okay so my bishop is
going to get killed I think let's do
this I want to stop this advance I don't
want I upon it to keep a piece posted on
this d5 Skrull we're about even on time
like I have to watch out for mates here
let's let's let's line something up on
g2 and force a weakness come on can I
take advantage of this weakness somehow
this D file is gonna open up maybe
Knight f8 is a good way to defend
against that h2 square and let me keep
this night out I think my Queens gonna
have to come over here to anticipate the
eventual opening up of this D file so
I'm gonna get my rook here I don't know
about doing this is a great idea because
then there's a timely capture on c5 my
knight I think wants to play to f8 I'm
not sure what their plan is okay yeah
now I know what their plan is my knight
wants to play here in fact put pressure
on this pawn and this pawn so can I
transfer my Queen over there somehow
what's this Knight up to I think he
might want to go into g5 let me stop
that altogether I could actually play a
knight here but that super risky Knight
f6 would not work I could do this I'm
opening up my queen I hope it's okay
we're gonna have a bunch of exchanges on
the D file here huh now that's
interesting I really want to take that
Knight know I should be jumping in here
is there anything scary going on there
might be something with f6 or Knight
here but now I have that covered
actually my last move I'm putting
pressure on this pawn pawn push here
makes things very weak right okay my
knight needs to go somewhere else maybe
that's not a knight by the way my knight
needs to go somewhere else and then I
move my best shot okay they're making
they're making a moves like that too
okay that's and I don't know what to do
move
you make a move I don't know what to do
okay I guess we're gonna exchange pawn
push I can't take right here I really
can't do okay yeah I mean I'm I'm in a
position where I just don't know what to
do
Bishop here I can take this knight
eventually okay Queen takes I could take
this pawn after this capture on the B
file I had that rule available this
night is really good but can I really
put them to good use
who needs work right now is my night on
f8 I don't need to defend against h7
anymore but it's maybe not long off come
to think of it okay I think I take here
first then I take the rook the knight
has to recapture and wise I take the
knight in here or there's that night
here there I have this covered this f6
move we're still dead even on the clock
Knight takes pawn I don't have maybe I
could get my bishop in a different
position
the Queen is restricted to this square
right here
I want my bishop on this square I think
Knight e5 moves as well I could move
here he is a passed pawn maybe I could
get him going let's get my knight
working I want to jump into this square
I have that covered don't I my queens
are protected so I'm in a pin right now
I have to take like this am I gonna be
able to save this okay let me go we're
clean here get out of the pin and then
actually Queen here isn't everything
defended almost oh you know what I have
to do have to move fast my knight has to
drop back here g5 is gonna be played
let's keep going like this 35 37 my
knight here I'm gonna be dropping that
pot I have Queen Chex maybe I could do
something with that you keep you running
with this right now he's in trouble I
want to get my queen really active my
Knights are connected I'm not even sure
my queen is doing there
could take that I can maybe have some
checks here now that's covered I do this
this is real I could give a check you
throw some checks in maybe more checks
19 to 16 hitting the Queen and on the
night and then jump my night in here
now I'm gonna end up in a fork can feel
it I can feel the fork happening soon oh
here comes a fork a big Fork
Oh crazy nights tricky nights tricky
tricky tricky nights there it is night
ah
did I tell you that tricky night is
there oh I could've got the Queen and
I've been ton oh no time what a game oh
that was an awesome game those tricky
nights were dangerous that double check
oh and that was last one of the game
alright
what a tournament five games five out of
five very good
four three two one write and order
alright oh those tricky nights it didn't
even come down to a position at that
point it came down to time in a very
very even end game oh good tournament
good games all
you